so kyle i understand that uh you were
responsible for the beyonce concert
yep time for change and then uh
through that the documentary was also
shown
on wow so how did japanese audiences
respond to beyonce's concert
and her documentary yeah she's very very
popular in japan too
and then there she's kind of fashion
icon for the younger audience
and ours subscriber
is the like 40s and 50s mainly
but we want to try to up appeal to the
younger audience as well
so of course beyonce is the
you know they're very famous and and
then i really like the concept of the
concert
because the uh time for
change is the um
you know the enhanced women's power
so still you know the
u.s sometimes people says it's the male
oriented society but
in japan it's much more the completely
oriented society so
i you know that exactly the chamfer
change
to japan
you